so today we're going to talk about the
seven reasons why you are up through the
night and you can't sleep through the
entire night if you have a problem
sleeping this is a very important video
I've done other videos that explain
parts of this but I've never done a
video that explains all the reasons so
this is based on working with 40,000
people over 29 years okay so this is the
stuff that will help you number one high
blood sugar if you're diabetic or a
pre-diabetic and you have high blood
sugars what happens is that water
follows this sugar so you're gonna end
up peeing more especially at night
so just by fixing the blood sugar issue
you'll be able to hold the urine a lot
longer so if you're new to my channel I
put a link down below of how to do that
number two which relates to one high
insulin which is a little different
insulin stimulates something called the
sympathetic nervous system the system
that's called the flutter fight like
part of the nervous system that controls
the stress signals okay when you have
too much of this system you will not be
able to hold your bladder so you're
going to want to get up and go to the
bathroom over and over and over again so
you want to decrease insulin the same
solution that fixes this will fix this I
put a link down below
number three high cortisol this is the
adrenal hormone this is a stress hormone
and what happens is when you go to bed
at night normally you go through four
waves of sleep these are called
circadian waves from a superficial wave
which is the REM sleep to the deep
delta-wave sleep right here with higher
levels of cortisol not only are you not
able to get into the deeper sleep cycles
but usually you're going to end up
waking up about 2:00 a.m. in the morning
which is exactly when you should have
the deepest sleep and I used to have
this problem as well because I had high
cortisol but you wake up at 2:00 and you
are completely awake in fact you're more
awake in the middle of the night than
you are during the day yet sometimes
they're flipped so in the middle of
night when you should be sleeping that's
when you're the most awake and then when
you wake up in the morning you're the
most tired
right here this situation usually occurs
when you have years of stress I put a
link down below of exactly what to do
about it it's in my stress webinar I
show you how to fix this problem right
here but another thing you can do as a
temporary solution is to take higher
amounts of vitamin d3 it can really help
restore your cortisol levels and before
too much coffee and tea because of the
caffeine it's a stimulant and it takes a
certain amount for your liver to get rid
of that caffeine personally I consume
one small cup of coffee in the morning
that says I don't have any tea anything
else
simply because I used to drink a ton of
coffee it's just something you need to
be aware of because if you're doing
everything else right and you're just
doing a little too much of this or too
much of this that could be the reason
why you're just not sleeping through the
night number five
too much artificial light so let's say
for example you have a computer job or
you're behind your computer all day long
and you have this LED screen and you're
in your eyes this is definitely not good
for the activation of certain hormones
that help you sleep at night so you want
to get a full spectrum light around your
desk in your computer and you also want
to go for a walk
to offset the sitting and from the
computer all day long and also get some
vitamin D or in sunlight on your face
and also one last point when you're out
in the Sun and I see people wear the
dark glasses and they don't get any Sun
in their eyes and not to look into the
Sun at 12 o'clock noon okay but just
allow the natural sunlight to penetrate
the eyes so you can have somewhat of a
recharging effect all right number six
sleep apnea very common very simple
solution all you have to do well this is
a temporary solution because vitamin b1
helps a certain area in the brainstem
that's involved with breathing okay the
breathing centers and if you're
deficient you're gonna have a big
problem with this at night so it's just
a matter of taking some b1 and also
getting rid of the reason why
you're depleted in b1 the most common
one is you're consuming too many
carbohydrates okay so it comes back to
these two right here you need to lower
the carbohydrates in your diet and you
also need to take nutritional yeast
which has the natural b1 versus a
synthetic vitamin also be one helps the
excessive thinking all the time that
people are have anxiety and they're
worried all the time and that nervous
tension that's going to keep you from
sleeping as well and there's one more
condition called lactic acidosis as a
byproduct of having too much
carbohydrate and diet and that can build
up and that can actually throw up your
ph well it just so happens that vitamin
b1 gets rid of this this lactic acid
okay
all right I want to talk about the last
one number seven which is pH that can
affect your sleep there's two situations
one is that your body is too alkaline
and the other is your body's too acid
now if you're too alkaline
you're gonna have a lot of cramping your
muscles are gonna be tense and tight and
there's nothing that will wake you up
faster than having a charley horse in
the middle of the night okay vitamin D
will also help this vitamin d3 but in
reality you may want to take some
outside of vinegar because these
minerals the alkaline minerals
especially like the magnesium potassium
calcium and even sodium need a certain
pH for those minerals to be activated if
your pH is too alkaline
these minerals just don't work and so
you're gonna have a lot of cramping
muscles techne a lot of spasms things
like that so it's just a matter of
adding the absolute vinegar vitamin d3
would help your calcium absorption
because if you're low in calcium you
won't be able to relax too so you might
be exhausted but your head won't turn
off okay vitamin D will help you with
that vitamin D will also help you with
the high cortisol but also it can act as
an off switch if you're laying there at
night you just can't wind down
can help getting you in that deeper
delta-wave sleep now one time I remember
drinking too much kombucha tea it comes
in a bottle like this and it's very
carbonated very acidic I drank the whole
thing when normally you should drink
like half of it or less than that and I
remember just having these symptoms
right here my pulse rate went up I was
really restless the nervous system was
on edge higher pulse rate and air hunger
so I was sighing frequently like I just
couldn't get enough air so what you need
to do for this one is alkalize the body
and you can do it several ways you can
do with calcium magnesium or potassium
now you have all seven reasons why
you're not sleeping apply the one that
fits your situation and comment below if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos